[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur tv
soixante dix huit pour un nouveau numéro
du 7 8 sociétés le rendez vous
hebdomadaire où l'on discute des sujets
qui font l'actualité
tag déjections canines ou encore dépôts
sauvages c'est ce qu'on appelle des
incivilités les communes et
agglomérations multiplient les actions
pour limiter ou faire disparaître ces
comportements mais avec quels moyens on
en parle avec nos invités sonia breux
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes la maire de
saint cyr d'école et joséphine colmate
verger bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes la mr2
plaisir et je vais commencer avec vous
madame coleman berger parce que du 20 au
30 octobre la ville organisé sa première
semaine de la citoyenneté vous
souhaitiez que les plaisirs oies se sont
tous concernés par la vie de la commune
et dans le programme il y avait un mur
des incivilités c'est un sujet qui
relève justement de la citoyenneté
je pense que oui
c'est un besoin aussi de s'exprimer sur
le sujet donc le mur le mur permettait à
des jeunes aussi de mieux comprendre
peut-être est de nous faire comprendre
comment ils leur santé ce qui est l
incivilité c'est vrai que sur cette
semaine nous avons eu pas mal d'action
et surtout une campagne d'affichage ac
je dirais trash excusez moi du terme
mais pour pour un petit peu choqué parce
que les incivilités sa chair tout lourde
vraiment alors du côté de saint cyr
l'école en 2018 un centre de supervision
intercommunale été lancée à fontenay le
fleury concernés fontenay bois d'arcy et
saint cyr l'école son but traiter des
affaires d'incivilités de sécurité il
est toujours actif
oui bien sûr notre centre de visionnage
est toujours actif les
écrans sont bien entendu sur le centre
intercommunal mais aussi visible de la
part du du commissariat de police
nationale et du commissariat de police
municipale
quelles sont les principales les
incivilités ou auxquels vous êtes
confrontés sur saint cyr l'école
je crois que c'est malheureusement des
sujets que nous partageons au niveau
national
c'est la joie la chance l'envi d'avoir
un chien et jamais de me ramasser les
déjections canines sur les trottoirs ou
dans les espaces verts c'est sortir ces
encombrants le lendemain du passage
annoncé
c'est une
jeter des déchets dans la rue sans
vraiment regarder
la gêne occasionnée
ou petites
petite anecdote on a sorti une
contre-publicité long mais un mégot de
cigarette écrasé dans une assiette sur
une table de restaurant
et dans laquelle on dit ça vous choque
et bien sûr nos trottoirs aussi et bien
c'est un peu le genre d'incivisme qu'on
rencontre assez régulièrement à la
sortie des cachets sur les en hausse sur
des abris sous des abris bus et c'est ce
qu'on aimerait voir disparaître c'est
les mêmes problématiques sur plaisir
madame clémence berger mais c'est à peu
près la même chose a donc vous savez on
a en a à g 4 qui est un moyen de
répondre à nos habitants sur sous 24
heures et on a aussi le pav ce qu'on
appelle le plaisir à votre écoute et
depuis là depuis cette année en tout cas
2021 on a recensé sur tout ce qui est
par exemple
les stationnements gênants qui vraiment
pose problème aussi plus de 170 appels
concernant tout cela et puis sur les
nuisances dont parlait ma connection ya
séparé il ya un an et demi dans saw 6 de
déjections canines plus de plus de 140
appels et au niveau de la propreté alors
je ne peux que rejoindre ma collègue sur
tout ce qui est dépôts sauvages est
effectivement décalage de dépôt des
poubelles on a eu plus de 250 appels et
bien de deux gènes à ce niveau là que je
vous parle même pas de tout ce qui est
ainsi bilité au niveau des vitesses des
voitures des des mobylettes des rodéos
enfin bref je crois qu'on a exactement
les mêmes soucis et les mêmes problèmes
avec ce gars parmi les incivilités il ya
aussi les dépôts sauvages dans les
événements maire excédé qui est passé à
la manière forte en 2010 la ville de
vélizy villacoublay fait un retour à
l'envoyeur et envoie des notes salées
regard des
dernières en date 12000 euros pour cet
habitant de vélizy-villacoublay pris en
flagrant délit de dépôts sauvages le
maire n'en n'est pas à son coup d'essai
depuis 2010 est pascal thévenot a pris
la décision de faire payer les
contrevenants se la faire de tous et on
est tous victimes de dépôts sauvages et
notamment en 2017 il y avait le quartier
loi où on était en train de s'éteindre
au chantier on supprime une dalle de
vingt mille mètres carrés dont il y
avait des camions c'était facile de
venir déposer des gravats parmi les
calmants du chantier est donc là on en a
eu assez c'est là qu'on avait mis on
avait déclaré en préfecture une caméra
de ceux de surveillance et j'avais dit
que le premier qu'on attrape je lui
ramène et ça a pas raté il y en a qui a
balancé attaqué par l'administré puis
blanchi par la justice le maire a choisi
de continuer la lutte contre les dépôts
sauvages et les incivilités j'ai fait
passer
une délibération au conseil municipal
qui pour des frais de nettoyage donc ce
n'est pas une n'est pas une amende c'est
des frais nettoyage forfaitaire de 150
euros + 150 euros par kilo dire que de
temps en temps on fait des opérations
coup de poing grâce à la
vidéosurveillance le but faire prendre
conscience aux administrés de l'impact
des dépôts sauvages une initiative
plutôt bien accueilli moi je pense il a
bien raison
je pense qu'il faut pas mettre ses
déchetteries un apport nous en même
temps il ya ce qu'il faut pour les
mettre ailleurs que sur le trottoir donc
tu pas sauf que ce soit une attaque
venant du maire à moment donné les
trottoirs sont et pour tout le monde
tout dépôt sauvage doit être puni voilà
on n'a pas le droit de salir la nature
comme ça depuis 2010 est la mairie n'est
quasiment plus victimes de dépôts
sauvages même en forêt
sonia bros passer par le portefeuille
c'est une solution pour que les gens
comprennent
quand j'aurais aimé vous dire non mais
je crois que clairement la preuve a été
faite que oui donc oui passer par le
portefeuille dont ne nous mentons pas ça
demande aussi des moyens exceptionnels
de la part de des communes ça veut dire
qu'il faut mettre une vidéo protection
nomades ça veut dire qu'il faut
avoir les agents nécessaires pour
pouvoir visionner ce n'est pas
complètement anodin en revanche
malheureusement il n'y a pas d'autre
choix ou à saint cyr très régulièrement
lorsque nous avons à faire des dépôts
sauvages et bien nos agents regarde s'il
n'y a pas une adresse un courrier
quelque chose et derrière
bien sûr nous verbalisons
joséphine coleman vergeer plaisir aussi
il faut passer par le portefeuille
quelle sanction vous pouvez appliquer
vous en tant que maire alors on a mis en
place aussi une démarche
pas aussi puissante peut-être que notre
collègue de vélizy mais en tout cas avec
des banderoles dans certains quartiers
où il ya marqué le quartier n'est pas
une poubelle toujours fait de ce côté
communication un peu forte avec 1500
euros d'amande et on a réussi à attraper
certaines personnes c'est à dire je suis
désolé de le dire mais certaines
certaines incivilités de la part de
certaines entreprises qui faisait payer
bien sûr
le ramassage de ces déchets pour les
ramener dans les déchetteries en vérité
ne le faisais pas ils venaient les
dépôts c'est comme ça sur le trottoir et
dans les quartiers donc on a aussi mis
en place quelque chose d'assez d' assez
virulent mais c'est vrai que comme
disait sonia on ne peut pas mettre non
plus des caméras partout c'est assez
complexe et difficile mais ça s'est su
et donc ça s'est un peu calmé au niveau
des dépôts sauvages ou est ce que vous
l'avez dit il ya des déchetteries vous
êtes toutes les deux sur des
agglomérations différentes
saint-quentin-en-yvelines pur plaisir
versailles grand parc pour saint cyr
l'école et finalement les gens ne vont
pas aux déchetteries un manque de
communication de volonté de se déplacer
comment vous l'analysez
danger enfin ce qui est en plus dommage
vous avez raison de le répéter si que
nous en avons plusieurs des déchets
triés sur 50 ans elles sont ouvertes à
toutes les communes les douze communes
donc tout le monde peut aller partout et
elles ont des amplitudes horaires très
très important tu penses que aujourd'hui
il ya un lâcher prise sur des efforts à
faire il faut charger sa voiture il faut
y aller faut le déposer donc bien sûr
beaucoup de gens le font moins
évidemment il ya pas mal de personnes
qui n'ont pas envie de faire ça c'est
tellement plus simple de prendre son
canapé et de le mettre sur le bord de la
route sur le trottoir de prétextant que
on viendra bien le chercher à un moment
donné et c'est ce qui se passe puisque
des agents de la ville
qu'un camion sans arrêt fonds le taux
fait le tour de la commune pour aller
ramasser tous ces déchets et je pense
que interne j'avais même envie d'arrêter
de le faire pour prouver que à un moment
donné ça suffit et je dis toujours la
ville n'est pas sale les saillies c'est
un peu facile mais c'est un petit peu ce
qu'on ressent quand même oui à
saint-cyr-l'ecole vous avez aussi des
agents dédiés à ça il est plein j'aime
le présenter autrement nous avons mis en
place la le patrouilleur de
l'environnement
dont l'objectif premier n'est pas
forcément de ramasser des dépôts
sauvages
est plutôt de les signaler parce qu'en
fait il est équipé de telle façon il lui
ne pourrait pas le faire
le patrouilleur de l'environnement c'est
une camionnette c'est un investissement
de 2 à peu près trente cinq mille euros
dans un véhicule est à peu près 6000
euros dans un temps d de l'outillage
qui se promène dans la ville qui a bien
sûr des ordres de mission mais qui a
aussi pour premier ordre de mission dès
qu'ils voient constate un désordre de
pouvoir s'arrêter pour le faire
j'entends par des ordres un tag sur un
sur un mur un endroit où on aurait collé
des affichettes sur un poteau et je vous
assure qu'en cette période
pré-présidentielle nous commençons à
voir fleurir ceci surtout nos poteaux ce
qui est pas très agréable et ensuite
évidemment lorsqu'il voit des dépôts
sauvages comme je vous disais son
équipage ne lui permet pas de l'est
forcément de les prendre mais il
communique avec les équipes qui viennent
les récupérer mais je suis d'accord avec
ma collègue joséphine
concrètement nous sommes en train de
mettre l'argent public l'argent chacun
d'entre nous pour des gens qui ne
respectent pas et qu'ils n'ont pas envie
de se fatiguer à aller jusqu'à la
déchetterie
c'est un petit peu comme les personnes
qui se garent c'était encore un autre un
civisme
alors je vous en perdu madame bro
justement oui des sensibilités il y en a
de toutes sortes j'avais choisi de
plutôt de mode de me concentrer sur les
les déchets tout ça parce que la gazette
des communes indiqué en juillet 2020 que
le budget annuel moyen des communes et
collectivités pour lutter contre les
dépôts sauvages c'est 59 mille euros ça
paraît énorme
madame coleman bergès et vous êtes dans
ces eaux là
on est dans ces eaux là effectivement on
se retrouve avec des sommes qui sont en
augmentation permanente c'est pour ça
que ce que vous évoquez tout à l'heure
sur attaqué le porte monnaie c'est
véritablement une des solutions c'est
dommage à dire on fait de la prévention
pourtant vous savez au niveau des
enfants au niveau des centres de loisirs
haut niveau parce qu'on passe par les
enfants pour sensibiliser tout cela et
malgré tout on s'aperçoit qu'il ya un
véritable lâcher prise pour avoir
échangé avec pas mal de mes collègues
maires on se rend compte que après le
confinement il y a eu vraiment une
augmentation des incivilités sur les
collectivités de tous ordres vraiment de
tous ordres et ça c'est très compliqué
pour nous parce que comme je dis on peut
pas être derrière chaque citoyen qui se
comporte mal et donc entre la prévention
et entre le fait que tout le monde
souhaite avoir une vie propre et bien on
dépense de plus en plus d'argent et ce
chiffre de ne m'interpelle pas et je le
trouve tout à fait malheureusement
cohérent avec la situation actuelle le
temps passe on a perdu madame roux qui a
dû se déconnecter je vous propose que
nous en restions sur ces mots merci de
nous avoir suivi on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine pour un nouveau temps
des changes
[Musique]